hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor again and
today we're gonna be talking about the
patch notes for title update 1.22 this
really long patches on what majority of
bug fixes but also some minor
adjustments as well and then going into
new explanations about the new title I
like the new training features like
training trials warrior trials the arena
mode all that good stuff that's going to
be coming basically tomorrow on April
19th which is tomorrow on Thursday but
really quickly I just want to say thank
you guys for making me hit 10k subs you
guys are the absolute goats you guys are
[ __ ] awesome I'm gonna be doing a Q&A
as well as the face reveal since
everybody's been wanting that [ __ ] I'm
gonna be doing the Q a Q&A so any
basically in the comments below ask me
any questions you have about me and I'll
gladly put them in the video and answer
them and be really nice so you can get a
discussion going during that video what
that boys like the video if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I cover the
leaks the information the patch notes
the new heroes anything regarding
foreign and the informational side of
like the cover and with that let's get
started with the video so first up we're
gonna be talking about the new training
features coming and this is not anything
to do with the patch notes this is
strictly arena mode training trials all
that beautiful type [ __ ] I'm gonna have
the training mode trailer in the
background from Ubisoft I shot it to
those guys from acre the trailer I'm
going to be showing little bits of it
from the trailer in the backgrounds you
guys can get an understanding of what
I'm talking about but basically this is
going to be starting April 19th which as
I said is tomorrow on Thursday before on
our community we'll have free access to
a series of new training features this
includes four new settings to help
players learn the game from basic
apprentice skills to advanced warrior
techniques the first one is the training
media section the training media section
contains tutorial videos on game modes
if you are curious or have any questions
about game modes features heroes or the
faction war
you can browse this section for more
information now I'm assuming this is
means whenever you go to a hero and you
can click on the how to play section
there's the advanced and basic tutorial
on how to play that hero I'm assuming
all that stuff is going to be put into
one little folder or one little section
and that's going to be what's called the
training media so if you ever need a
specific help for a hero or a game-mode
or anything like that you can go to that
tab next up is the apprentice Charles
and Warrior Trials the goal of the
apprentice Charles is to understand and
master the game's basic mechanics such
as guard mode and attacking beginners
techniques you will be graded as you go
so you know which skills need
approvement in which will be given
rewards
than your performance the purpose is to
guide you through the basics of the art
of battle so you're free to fight once
you hit the battlefield and in the
warrior trials which is a little bit
different from The Apprentice trials is
it improves the players knowledge of a
more advanced technique for example it
will learn how to trick enemies by
fainting attacks or take out multiple
enemies with a single zone attack as
with The Apprentice trials you will earn
rewards based on performance now just to
quickly summarize that The Apprentice
trials is for the beginners and the
warrior trials is going to be for people
at the advanced technique so I would
rana say just play through these anyway
since i'm gonna go over the rewards in a
second but if you don't feel like it you
might just want to hop to the warrior
trials if you've already familiar with
the game or if you're new Hopps the
apprentice one for the apprentice trial
rewards this is going to be successfully
completed the apprentice trials to get
these rewards you're going to be getting
the glorious determination ornament
personally to me that doesn't look as
worth it but that's entirely up to you
since I have better ornaments that I
like to equip on top of that you're
going to be getting the emblem symbol
called apprentice sigil and the
apprentice trials emblem outline as well
as the apprentice sigil for your
customization symbol so you can have it
on your emblem and for your clothes and
on top of that you're gonna be getting
two thousand steel and one scavenger
crate for the warrior trials it's going
to be a little bit of a similar type
aspect where you're going to be getting
an ornament this is going to be the
skilled master ornament the experts
digital emblem and for your
customization as well on your hero as
well as the warrior trials emblem
outline and you're also going to be
getting one scavenger crate in 1500
steel so if you're really not into the
rewards you might as well do this since
you're gonna be getting two extra
scavenger crates and 3,500 steel just
for doing something that may or may not
take 10 to 15 minutes to do and then
lastly is probably everybody's favorite
part is the training arena in the arena
players will discover the ultimate for
honor training run they will be able to
choose any hero and adjust the game
settings to play the way you want
for example even setup health stamina
and revenge modifiers in game players
can customize their AI enemies to
practice new moves and prepare for
specific scenarios the 3 arena map shown
will be also available online in duel
and brawl game modes which we talked
about last week now just in case you are
a little bit confused on what that means
basically it's similar to the way Mortal
Kombat and just this basically any
NetherRealm type fighting game likes to
handle their training mode in the aspect
of that is that you could have full
health and not take any damage
and then make sure that the opponent
does a specific move for example if I
want to practice a zone attack that I'm
not really good would say I want to
practice peacekeeper zone and I want to
get down the parry times I basically
just set the move so that she only does
that weapon and then I get down the
parry timing are the deflect timing or
whatever happens to be now obviously it
doesn't have to be for a zone attack it
could be anything if you're having
trouble trying to parry certain attacks
or even just block certain attacks in
general you can do that as well and you
can even mix and match that maybe they
only do regular moves and not the zone
attack or only do regular moves and no
combos or only combos and shift like
that personally for me though I believe
that it's going to really help the
beginners out to get familiar with the
game but it's also going to help out the
veteran players just a little bit mostly
with these zone parry timings that is
all for the new training at settings and
all that good stuff coming on this
Thursday on April 19th just so you know
so now we're going to move into the
actual patch notes of live of the live
title update 1.22
now also in this patch they go over some
of the stuff from the training arena
apprentice and warrior trials in the
training media tab as well so we're just
gonna go over just a little bit more
info on that as well as getting into the
majority of the patch now most of this
patch was full of bug fixes so I'm only
going to be talking about the most
important parts if there is a bug fix
that definitely is necessary I will
bring it up other than that I'm gonna be
bringing up most of the adjustments if
you want to see everything in this patch
that it'll be in the link down in the
description if you want to follow along
or read every single thing that is
entirely up to you but with this it
starts off with the new tutorial modes
and for the apprentice trials it says 5
training scenarios on the core of the
art of battle the apprentice charles
likes to focus on guard mode attacking
dodging and rolling basic guard braking
and stamina management with the warrior
charles being the more advanced one
focusing on more of assassin defense
external block or venge mud zone attack
execution parry fainting and opening and
advanced guard break techniques so like
I said if you're more of a beginner
player definitely hop onto the
apprentice one or if you're one of a
veteran player you can obviously hop
onto the warrior one but you might as
well do the apprentice one since you're
getting more steel and you can just get
free steel really quickly the new maps
that are going to be coming in the arena
mode are the bring the pit in the
sanctuary for each of the faction if you
want to look at that you can go to my
recent video from last week it'll be at
via it'll be in the I on the top right
or at the
and of this video if you want to check
that out but with the in terms of
fighters for all heroes it's going to be
the adjustment on back dodge which like
we like I said we talked about last week
basically making it so that assassins
can't back dodge out of combat if
they're low on health or out of stamina
making this a little bit more balanced
Conquer got two adjustments and that is
the charging shield crush it now hits
causes the opponent to spend seven
hundred milliseconds falling instead of
eight hundred the reason for this was
because people would usually shield
crush and then go into a shield bash
after it since because the shield bash
is a shorter window from when you're
trying to get up so they decreased it so
you do have a little bit of time to get
out of that if they try to show bash you
and speaking of shield bash the knock
back distance is going to be 1.5 meters
as opposed to 1.75 meters so it's going
to be a shorter distance when you're
getting smacked with it and as well all
of conkers light attacks now do 13
damage that used to be 15 for berserker
and specific he got and adjusted damage
value for his slashing rush move the
first strike now does eight damage as
opposed to 15 the second strike damage
now does eight instead of ten and the
third now does eight instead of 15 so
basically every single move on the
slashing rush combo now does eight
damage so it's a little bit less than
before on top of that it also makes it a
little bit less efficient at evading
combat the first strike of slashing rush
can now be parried in the first strike
of slashing rush and a little longer has
backward movement it used to be two
meters backwards and reduced all hit
trajectories from that move as well he
also got another adjustment to his own
attack and they all do decrease damage
the first strike on the zone attack used
to do nine damage and now that does six
and the second third and fourth strike
used to do seven damage now it does six
so once again a little bit of a decrease
on his own attack and basically
decreasing the overall damage from what
it used to be shinobi got another
adjustment and that's basically very
simple it's just this backward strafe
speed has now been reduced by 30%
the developer comet is that this is
meant to be coupled with the global back
dodge nerf we intended for characters to
be less effective at avoiding combat
that's why they gave his strafe speed
just a little bit of hurt or of a
reduction on speed we talked about this
last week as well but Centurion did get
two adjustments on top of a bunch of
other bug fixes but those adjustments
include an increase of health from 110
to 120 so an extra tenth health and
added a new chain to the Centurions move
set which is now a light heavy he used
to have a light light heavy and
still does but the only issue is that
with the light light heavy combo people
would parry or block the second
basically making it really redundant so
they basically took out the second light
now having a light heavy combo my boy
gladiator got an adjustment and that is
his backwards straight speed has now
been reduced by 12.5% basically like we
talked about with shinobi and the other
assassins being them so that they can
back dodge out of fights and all that he
can now no longer do that as well it's a
sad nerf but it was definitely well
needed
there was also an adjustment for
Highlander that fixed the issue that
caused his Highlander sprint attack to
not be effective at killing soldiers the
second attack no longer starts when the
previous strike hits a target instead it
always starts when the Miss recovery
would begin this allows the attack to
better cleveland ends and be useful for
killing soldiers the second strike can
be aimed at the different target than
the first rotation is slightly increased
and the trajectory is slightly longer to
better match the blade so basically
making his front attack way better at
killing minions and maybe even killing
opponents but this is mostly used for
minions shaman also happened to
beginning an adjustment as well and if
an external attacker hits the shaman
during predators mercy and the opponent
is freed the opponent will be cleansed
of bleed I guess this was a thing before
where the shaman jumped on the opponent
and they had predators mercy obviously
going to for that bite and then they
would get knocked off the opponent would
still have bleed on them so that they
could just go for a second jump and then
there it basically be redundant now once
that happens if you happen to be freed
by your teammate in your being bit by
shaman the bleed will come off of you so
now she can only do the head bolt which
is a really good adjustment in my
opinion and that's about it for the
patch
like I said majority of this was bug
fixes that had to do with Maps controls
sound UI there was tons of bug fixes and
so I'm very glad that the devs are
hopping on and doing these bug focus
which is really good there wasn't as
many adjustments but there is still some
hero balance changes that still need to
be taken care of like I said if you do
want to see every single thing and the
patch notes that'll be in the
description and I specifically remember
last stream they talked about how in
this patch majority of the characters
are going to be getting you know some
type of change whether it be bug fixes
or some type of adjustment but not all
of them and then also a little sneak
peek on which heroes are probably going
to get reworked because they don't
a lot of bug fixes anything like that
and it looks like valkyrie Orochi and it
seems like peacekeeper are going to be
the people that might get reworked next
season the Valkyrie had one bug fix for
one of her executions peacekeeper was
mentioned but didn't have anything
underneath her name and Orochi was
nowhere it can be found in the patch
notes so that leads me to believe that
these are going to be the three
characters of season 6 that are going to
be reworked so be that as it may this
may not even be true and I might just be
talking out of my ass but it seems like
it's the most likely story let me know
what you guys think about that in the
comments below it really enough to let
me know your thoughts about the patch
about the training mod about literally
anything I talked about in this video
but that's gonna be the end of the video
today guys Cyrus this one was a little
bit on the longer side you know I'm not
really big on making long videos but I
need to talk about everything that
needed to be said during this so that
was definitely well needed as I said
thank you guys for 10,000 subs if you do
want a shout or if you do want to show
me or ask me a question anything like
that about me or about anything during
the Q&A video when I happen to get
around to that definitely just put it in
the comments below I'll be taking it
from the comments and all that good [ __ ]
as well so I'll definitely be reading
about those out in video like the video
if you did enjoy I really just help me
out subscribe if you're new like I said
in the beginning I covered the
informational site a foreigner that
being leaks the news the patch notes all
that informational side anything
upcoming in the game I like to cover my
two most recent videos are going to be
on screen if you guys do want to check
that out with that guys hope you have a
great rest your day thank you guys for
10,000 subs you guys are the absolute
goats and peace out